we're already somewhat familiar with the
idea of division if I were to say eight
divided by two you could think of that
as eight objects so one two three four
five six seven eight divided into equal
groups of two and so how many equal
groups of two could you have well you
could have one two three or four groups
of two and so you'd say eight divided by
two is equal to four another way we
could have thought about that is you
have one two three four five six seven
eight and if you were to divide it into
two equal groups well you could have one
group of four made a little bit cleaner
one group of four and then a second
group of four so two equal groups how
many in each of those equal groups well
they're four in each of those groups and
so once again eight divided by two is
equal to four now we're going to extend
our knowledge of division by starting to
think about things that don't divide
evenly so what if we were to say what is
8/3 pause this video and see if you
could think about that a little bit all
right
so let's draw eight objects again one
two three four five six seven eight and
one way to think about it is how we
thought about it here is can we make can
we divide this into groups that all have
three in them and how many groups would
we be able to make of three let's try it
out I can make this group of three I can
make this second group of three but I
can't make any more groups of three and
I what I have left over are these two
and so the way that you would describe
this or one way to describe this is hey
I was able to make two groups of three
so it's equal to two and there's some
left over there's a remainder let me
write that down important concept there
is a remainder of two as well and so
sometimes it's written as just a
lowercase R
of to another way to think about it is
to this 2 times 3 6 and then if you were
to put back that remainder that's how
you can get to 8 now another way you
could think about it is how we thought
about in the second example with 8
divided by 2 let me draw eight objects
again 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and you could say
hey let me divide that 8 into 3 equal
groups so pause this video and see if
you can divide this into 3 equal groups
and then what might be left over alright
so I'm going to try to divide this into
3 equal groups I'm not going to be able
to put 4 in each of those groups because
I can only make 2 equal groups of 4 I'm
not gonna be able to put 3 into those 3
equal groups because that would actually
be outing 9 4 doing that
so each of my groups are gonna have to
be 2 so I could make one group of two
another group of 2 and there you go 3
equal groups of 2 so I was able to sort
out 3 equal groups of 2 with just these
six but once again I have a remainder
I'm not able to make use of these two
they're not able to fit into one of in
this case one of the three equal groups
if I said four equal groups then they
would fit in but if I just said three
equal groups cuz I'm dividing by 3 then
I have this leftover again let's do one
more example what if I were to ask you
what is what is 13 divided by divided by
4 pause this video and think about it
and as you might imagine there's will be
a remainder involved all right well
let's draw 13 objects 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 and we could try to divide
this into equal groups of 4 that's one
way to think about it so let's see
that's a group of 4 I got I have one
group of 4 that's a group of four I have
two groups of 4 and then that is a group
of 4 so I'm able to find the
equal groups of four so this is equal to
three another way to think about it four
goes into thirteen three times but then
I have this little lonely circle here I
have one left over I have a remainder of
one because four times three that gets
you to twelve but then if you want to
get to 13 well then you got to throw in
that remainder there